by the way today is jason kaplan's
birthday robin take a guess how old
jason is
let's see how good you are dear let me
take a really good look
now don't forget fatter people look old
so how's the diet going by the way
that's what i was still going it's still
[ __ ] going
did you snack during super bowl did you
break your diet or did you stick to it
no
i stuck with it i had cauliflower nachos
with non-fat cheese and
delightful my freezer is nothing but
broccoli and cauliflower
that's my entire because you could eat
the promises you could eat as much of it
as you want but then you put uh
toppings and things on it like you dip
it into stuff no no
mustard mustard because mustard has the
uh zero calories or calories and uh and
you can use spices you know like garlic
powder or something which has zero you
know so i'm following
the rules um so in other words a snack
during super bowl if you get
like crazy you could take chop up some
cauliflower
um dip the pieces in mustard and put a
little garlic powder on it and you'd be
zero
you'd be at zero calories you'd be at
zero calories according to their plan
you could eat that unlimited now i
haven't pulled the benji thing where i
just get a trough of cauliflower
how much weight have you lost about 13
pounds my official weigh into that's
tomorrow again
you mean after all this deprivation you
think you've only lost 13 pounds
you weigh like over 300 13 pounds is
like if you took a dump
well maybe you haven't tried that jason
i did do that i weighed myself
last week i weighed myself and i wasn't
happy with the results and i took a dump
and it was like a solid half pound
lighter i was like all right there we go
the uh original question rob was how old
is jason's birthday
how old is it it's his birthday yeah
jason is very youthful looking except
for the gray and his beard
thank you so go ahead i'm gonna say
45. i take it
you're 42. i like you older
yeah yeah i thought you were 58 so